[Music]
you're right guys we shouldn't talk
about nick's family on this
careful boys episode welcome back
everybody gotta be careful oh [ __ ]
that's the same sign as a conspiracy
corner remember that i thought it was
careful boiso with a b that's a
conspiracy in and of itself right uh
right here
cb no i was i was seeing two c's in my
mind that's right
right yeah careful choice
boys i know you want this that's what i
want but it's not hey do you guys know
that my grandfather had a koi pond
what so he wasn't racist is that
cultural appropriation
uh i don't know dude i always wanted a
koi pond that's really cool but
everybody has a koi pond like that's
like only a rich people have to eat
they don't have to be eight it's not
asian exclusive you know
chicken
depends if you named it koi pong or carp
he called it a coin hold on we have like
five conversations going on right now
that's what the best part of the show is
about welcome back to careful boys where
we talk about careful things guys very
careful we're talking about koi ponds i
guess yeah that's careful that's still
not the right tagline i feel like we
need something a little bit where we
talk about things that are acceptable
for 2021 thank you that's acceptable
then what can we talk about we're
talking about we can talk about how much
we can talk about house we love joe
biden yeah joe biden oh provided
no no no no that's not how it works you
love no no you love joe biden during the
election but when he's actually
president that's when you hate him
that's where he is that's all presidents
whoever's in charge come on we can do
better than this [ __ ] i'm just saying
the name of the sh the segment has to be
catchier with the so yeah where we talk
about
careful boys
i'm a big fan of redundancy though i
like yodling more okay
welcome back to careful boys where uh
careful boys hey
okay i see the comma now what about you
guys in the comments what do you guys
think maybe we should let them
participate and whatever is very popular
we'll just copy that but i also think
steve and anthony should have different
tag lines all right because he's got
careful boys he does careful boys and i
feel like that's anthony
steve
he has i'm more in your face you know
he's like what up there's careful boys
and he smashes the camera careful boys
we're careful okay i drink a mountain
dew
no whatever it's no big deal
it's whatever he's gonna do that four
times tomorrow
yeah that's pretty good that's a home
run i'm over here sitting trying to i'm
trying to get the comment they're so
heavy i'm like careful boys yeah how do
you feel about the combo careful
i don't work shopping i'm very open to
it got it okay i love how this is so jk
right everything is just on the fly like
they think we're sitting here and going
let's think of a good idea there's no
meaning it's scripted we memorized a lot
do you like the z
that was a comment i like this i just
saw it in the comment and i was like wow
the boys
the boys
i heard about it i didn't hate it
i like careful boys with the z i think
that's the only way to do it though it
is
especially because of our generation we
came from that it's almost like we're
like the precursor to boys to men we
just never became men instead of b-o-y-z
what if we didn't
i
that's really nice actually b-o-i-s-e
careful boise this guy loves idaho
yeah one of the first states to vote
i don't know i really like i thought the
colonization happened way on the east
side
you know it's for the first dates i i
like i like the devil what do you call
it when you de-evolve like the
devolution the destruction of yeah yeah
like the evolution the evolution of jk
news this is pretty [ __ ] awesome this
is not the evolution i think that's so
unfair
are we considered the [ __ ] not no
or the [ __ ] era dude listen jk news went
to space and now we're like we think
that mission was faked yeah yeah yeah we
didn't really land on the moon
let's take it back to [ __ ] earth bro
let's get back to back to browse [ __ ]
anyone who calls this a d evolution okay
i have been a part of jegane since the
beginning and i finally came around at
the de-evolution state come on
backstreet boys and vegas residents
we're like
all right let me tell you vegas
residency we're following in the
footsteps of britney spears okay so oh
we're in court
we're in a conservatory she had she had
her time right and then she had her time
again in vegas but now she had her time
again in the documentary it's a
different concept of the time i'm not
trying to get fake that's what i'm
saying though there's different phases
and stages trying to be heavy baby one
more time jamie spears of it all then
yeah i don't want to be [ __ ] in court
all the time britney spears yeah it's
anthony lee anthony's the james beard
hey careful boy
is michael has us in a stranglehold by
the ball sack i feel like mike should
always be on careful boys
i think he should be we should have a
separate seat for michael the thing that
people don't know is that michael
legally owns jk news and we just have to
do the show
i mean bart has barbell over here
we bought it three years ago there's a
five year time table before these guys
connected that's that's i bought way too
much [ __ ] crypto and now michael owns
all of it
joe just bought a truck he's putting the
mattress in the back yeah i wonder why
because you got to live in there okay
this is called over leverages it's
called listening the logo for careful
boys should be michael and he's like
this yeah
should be michael with puppet strings
like the in-sync album and then we're
all just like and we're like this
so michael's the overlord yeah dude
michael is the genius
he owns the show everyone knows the
topics he does the articles it's all
michael people like they're picking on
michael calling a murderer we're like
yeah we're picking on our boss
so bad who murders people
me and bart let it go ages ago exactly
you guys yes they got bought out we got
totally how many people do you think
michael has killed
well let's not say this on camera yet
until our contract is over oh yeah yeah
yeah
careful boys
careful boys thank you yeah we'll go
documentary on him after all this is
over
you know when the pandemic is over this
is the thing that i've been uh wanting
to do so like a lot of places are
allowing shows and stuff now right like
live shows yeah yeah i've always wanted
our group to go out and do live
tapings this group right here yeah live
jk news
yeah we've only done it like once right
we've done it no no we've done it like
three times
one was at the la car show with steve
aoki yeah he was completely delayed in
reaction like every time we talked
it was pretty dope but
because because he did a show he pulled
an all-nighter wait did you say steve
aoki yeah
kidding that was a delayed reaction oh
stupid
it's like you're a big fan
and and we were name-dropping if you
guys don't mind i've always had a dream
and you guys don't have to fulfill this
dream but of doing a live magic show
imagine the gathering no no no
an actual magic show where every time i
do a dangerous trick with my assistant
my assistant gets replaced by another
assistant
so the assistant's never the same so
they were they were dead they're
probably dead yeah well we don't know
the assumption the assumption so it's
like the prestige without any cloning at
all right but they're completely
different women even and then when you
hear them like when you pull them
you can hear something that's weird and
then you see a bunch of stage hands
running around and then it's weird and
then like all of a sudden the person
re-emerges but it's a different person
they're trying to be super comfortable
you like saw somebody in half you split
them up and then suddenly two different
halves that comes again and then i'm
clearly like i'm clearly like for a
second i'm like
and then i'm like i'm like try to keep
it together
different [ __ ] person when i open it
yeah yeah you're surprised that you're
like
and then my stage people come out and
they're like they take the thing away
and they're like
it's like a half body with guts flying
out scared as [ __ ] that has to be a jk
production
for our live show right we're gonna have
a live taping of jk news we're going to
have every talent from everyone like you
guys could do a dance routine [ __ ]
nick is going to teach people boxing
bart is going to [ __ ] lift weights
we'll play jabberwock video me and me
and me and steve yeah we're going to do
a motivational speech on [ __ ] how to
make money
yeah that'd be good
dude that's that's the best variety show
or or i'd do a dance with a jabberwocky
but everyone else is wearing a mask but
not me yo we should hire the
jabberwockies to open up at our
performance that'll be so sick nick can
dance in front of the jabberwocky's
video hell yeah
and i'm trying to like learn on the fly
i'm learning on the fly they're like
what oh we know we can get kendricks but
japan is that's gonna be a [ __ ] i
mean we're gonna have to play the video
that's tight y'all joking here is
literally the best advertising job he's
had
go see their [ __ ] i [ __ ] see the
jabberwocky show in vegas like five
times no [ __ ] if they don't know who we
are right now like lily no one on the
internet is talking about them but us
like [ __ ] hey give us throw us a
[ __ ] bomb throw some free take it to
the show give me a hoodie i want a jab
walkies hoodie they don't even know that
one of my closest friends was their
manager who i'm not even going to say
because he's not that close of a friend
so i retract that statement
she got still i was like
good don't give no freebies
but he's not my friend
we've given them so much prestige free
advertising dude
and mcdonald's but we that's why we
don't talk about mcdonald's that much no
more they duck us well actually they
sponsored b and everybody else but david
and a lot of other people they just
sponsor you
fat check from mcdonald's thank you guys
thank you so much
i needed that for my crypto
today's video is brought to you by
blenders
straight from san diego california my
state of california that's why i gotta
support this it's actually gonna be
probably my first and last sunglasses
ever because it's freaking just amazing
when i tell you about blender's eyewear
you're gonna be as hooked as i am on
these wonderful pieces yeah i love these
guys because these things are made here
in california it's super sunny and so
you know it's tested whether you're a
surfer a biker whatever sport that you
play you need to block out the sun and
it's sunny california so what better to
get sunglasses than that are made in
california yeah you don't want to get
sunglasses that are made in like a cave
why would you do it can't even test it
it's too dark in there yeah so i have a
very active outdoor lifestyle and i've
always wanted a pair that look real cool
but like i'm in the water or like i'm
mountain biking or whatever but it
always hurts me when these things get
scratched up or like it hurts the
pockets because a lot of these
sunglasses cost like hundreds of dollars
and what i like about these sunglasses
chase fisher the owner actually started
blenders while he was a surf instructor
so i like the entrepreneurial spirit
about he was selling him out of his
backpack it's super cool that it really
relates to me and i love entrepreneurs
who are trying to create something
that's made for people just like him
who's like surfing out there he's
probably got some cool shades on and
he's like man i keep losing him to the
ocean i'm tired of losing 300 bucks
every single time why don't i find an
alternative that's not only stylish and
cool like the designer wear but it's
also very affordable so when these
things happen i catch a wave it falls
off whatever then it's like
i'll just get another one yeah they're
mid-priced but they look and they feel
just like the big round ones and what's
sick is they have all of the ones that
are in trend so wireframes the plastic
frames like tortoise the polarized
lenses so pretty much every single pair
of sunglasses i already own that i like
that i always go to the ones where it's
mirror because like if i'm out there
like shooting or if i'm camping i like
the mirror effect so it's completely
blocks the sunlight they have those you
can pretty much find whatever you
already like on their site and what's
awesome is it's not just sunglasses that
they have blenders has prescription
glasses they have like the readers and
then they have the blue light blockers
and i'm ready for snowboard season
because they also have snow goggles
which is sick
so if you want to get 15 off your
blenders sunglasses go to
blendereyewear.com use the code off the
record vip to get 15 off the already
affordable sunglasses that's
blendereyewear.com use the code off the
record vip yo let's do this though no
i'm not even kidding all right so like
because uh right right when um the right
before the pandemic right we opened up a
patreon and um we were gonna do this
exclusive like
uh show for the patreon you know
uh what do you call it like a patreoners
right
and that was 2019. and then boom you
know the pandemic hit because we were
planning to do a whole thing in 2020 and
that [ __ ] just [ __ ] crashed on us so
i'm like
hopefully when we when we when open
things open up we should do something
for
everyone on patreon because we had some
loyal people that stuck around like
through thick and thin for like three
years now 100 so i'm like i want to find
who those peoples were
and then figure out a way to like give
them first dibs on the live shows if we
do it yep that'll be [ __ ] sick
yeah and we should do like a nationwide
tour so then they don't have to spend
money coming too far right so we'll go
all over idaho first state yeah idaho
the first
yeah so you have to pay 150
but you get the honor you get the
patriot honor of doing that that that's
what they do yeah they support us they
could right yeah support us more yeah
like they have the honor of supporting
us
the thing is we can actually do
florida right now we can do all these
other places right now
no dude the the patreoners get to leave
before the kinder show oh
yeah otherwise
it's
they get to leave otherwise they're
checking your ticket and you got to go
back to your [ __ ]
and you have to they got the flashlight
like absolutely no i get to [ __ ] my pc
how long is the kindred show it's an
hour now
it's an hour now
that's what perks are kids all i'm
saying is one day i'm making sure you
guys better be [ __ ] front row you all
are you dude i want to go see your
performer incorporating the noodles into
the live show
they bust out the microwave
and they [ __ ] cook the noodles
now yes
now yes i will do everything you guys
joke about on the show and you better
[ __ ] front rows each person audience
is connected to a noodle and they're all
sipping
it's going out there i'll be there a
thousand percent you just don't [ __ ]
invite me to [ __ ] that's why i never go
stop yelling at me right now on camera
okay i've never been invited to a
[ __ ] kinder show i bet i'll be
invited to a jab walking show before
i've never even been invited to a kinder
show dude i got half invited to an
auntie lee hangout party on my own
birthday and then no one showed up
he's like let's go play my arcade
machine i was like this would be really
fun
the perfect moment for my birthday i
didn't know we were doing it that night
dude i i know i was nervous to be honest
i didn't know we were doing it that day
i thought we were [ __ ] ranging i've
never been more roasted in a single day
here today and i love it i love it but
you [ __ ] when these cameras are off
you [ __ ] get it from me
[ __ ] talking about how my sister is
talking about how we don't [ __ ] do
those shows we didn't talk about the
[ __ ] noodles
like it's a problem we gotta sell news
because we can't make it you [ __ ] are
all going down and i swear to god when
the [ __ ] cameras go off oh my god
you pieces of [ __ ]
these [ __ ] you [ __ ] grateful fans
never [ __ ] get the full content these
pieces of [ __ ] camera goes off anthony
looks at me and he goes steve
you wanna do a shot
why are they laughing why are they
laughing
and also we've never said your sister is
hot
i was asking questions you did you and
you also said 10 cause i would bust
you i never said oh no that's what you
said not us
you said because i would bust too fast
you're a sick [ __ ] anthony you're a sick
[ __ ] dude it only took all day to get
out of them
that's why it takes shots you know all
right
all right let's go dude
i
hey she's probably really hot because
anthony looks pretty hot as a girl that
is a hot boy don't try to save your [ __ ]
my comments shut up dude you're a hot
boy it's a hot boy
everybody says it always thought you
dress hot you look hot you dance hot
dude for real
damn dude
who the [ __ ] did you look up right now
sung hi lee i remember her she was song
highly you don't remember sungky she was
like the hottest chick in the world
right is she an import model first of
all if this is my sister odd [ __ ]
i thought that was tia carrera's sister
for all we wanted to hear and who is she
though [ __ ] song he leaded i love
some music
[ __ ] yes dude i love the song i will
love her forever
[ __ ] i forgot her name i'll never turn
my back on somebody sung hi lee man she
was like a model model of that time
you're just perusing the gallery now i
[ __ ] jacked off to this
time
i'm trying to look for my favorite photo
i almost got i almost got suspended from
prince oh this is one of them which one
let me see oh yeah dude that was oh my
god wow you don't remember this photo
damn i wonder what she looks like now it
doesn't matter
go to auntie's house check her out she
has a bunch of people on instagram see
if she's on this family reunion dude
she's there she might be 50 something
now yeah she's there with my uncle bruce
and you think she's on instagram yeah
she might do like 50 something now
she was so hot back then anthony why are
you so ashamed of your success
are you so stingy with your sister so
not everyone has a hot sister like maybe
steve but not everyone has a heartbeat
how many more minutes we have this
[ __ ] anthony everyone has noodles at
costco everybody's down to talk about
their sister like steve
here's what's [ __ ] up about that
there's a lot of stigma going on about
the sister thing that i think is messed
up because a lot of guys don't have hot
sisters and so they don't understand
what it's like to actually have a hot as
[ __ ] system that's true
people don't understand that like you do
genuinely want to [ __ ] them really hard
you want to come and blow loads in them
and it sucks it [ __ ] sucks
when your sister's jiggling by you and
there's nothing you can do but wanna
[ __ ] come
you then you maybe you could put
yourself in my shoes but until then yeah
yeah guess what yeah he's alone you're
so brave steve dude he is so brave
he's the only one that's willing to
stand here and admit if we don't break
the stigma who the [ __ ] will i know
right he's standing up everyone on
pornhub
no they are all anonymous dude i'm not
here and now they only do the step
sister thing yeah they're not they're
not full blown like full blood
i got i'm talking about both parents is
my sister
pure a pure sister
100 matching dna
yeah he's talking about matching dna
identical
dna high chances of genetic diseases
cross-breeding as they say but that's
all a bunch of science [ __ ] you know
what
you're just trying to replicate the
royals
yeah hey he's a modern-day royal
for harry he's the same age as me and
he's balder than me
so hey do the math what that can't be
real that's not right it's not real
we're trying to look up sonny lee's
institute i mean
we want to train to be she has a
foundation
for instagram it's a prostitute
instagram and prostitutes at the same
time
[ __ ] he's so [ __ ] up
he's like we're looking up her in a big
titty society
big titty society
oh man
what does she look like modern day no it
only because she was like the hottest
[ __ ] back when i was like in junior high
type her name and then the year that
can't be 20 20. no way no way all right
let me type it again
there's no way that's her 21. and if it
was her she's keanu reeves dude what
kind of roof stuff like she didn't age
at all
remember when she was she was in a girl
next door sunky was that a movie what
took him out wait with alicia cuthbert
yeah she's she's one of the other she's
the asian porn chick that's like a
friend yeah that's something this is her
in 2021
that's not that's not her yeah but you
like this photo don't you yeah that's
she's too young that's a good photo
hardwood floor because i respect your
family
she should be in her late 40s mid 40s
now no i got to be like 50s you'd be
pretty stoked
i would hate if this was my sister
i would hate them now you get it what if
that's your fraternal twin sister that'd
be dope fraternal twin [ __ ] i should
start an instagram account like that
i think you should i think you should
now if she was your fraternal twin and
someone tell you to go [ __ ] yourself you
go [ __ ] your sister if i was an
identical twin i would [ __ ] my sister
fraternal if they told me [ __ ] myself be
like is there identical gender twins no
no right that would be incredible didn't
you hefner always [ __ ] twins
he was [ __ ] on twins oh yeah you
after did yeah
maybe just white blonde oh yeah that's
true huh he only liked blonde yeah you
like aryans you know
they're very aryan taste
even if they're fake blondes he liked
some of them their roots would be
growing out oh yeah i like that though i
do like that it's like blonde still okay
good for you oh this is one of my
favorite tv photos
oh that's a good picture
does that hurt i think that's a body
double it's all about calcium i think
wait it's the playboy a gut milk thing
is she a porn star no she was just a
nude model
she didn't do porn
it's like only fans
but back in the day back when it was on
paper but she she was on she was on like
import model stuff she should shave the
mustache yeah all right so i'm thinking
i'm [ __ ] like not a fan you should
shave her don't talk to my sister like
that
i don't like when girls have a low body
fat matches your your little thingamabob
a little bit
it runs in the family are you seriously
going to relate this to a [ __ ] vagina
right now from 1996. i think so you
piece of [ __ ] that's just your little
that picture literally
[ __ ] ass
it makes sense song hailee anthony lee
everything about you
just yo
i
needs
to
i hope you get a paper cut every day for
a year
with a hundred dollar bills
i was like why is my hat wet and i was
like oh yeah
i'm do [ __ ]
[Music]
you